by that time i reached down and felt my
leg and i'd seen so many people shot
over the years i knew
this wasn't just a through and through
because my hand was just saturated with
blood
[Music]
howard doss hey sean man we are back
from crime con back in the uh the
dungeon the studio we are man crime con
was a lot of fun uh it was really hot
out there and then we came back here and
now it's really hot it's really hot in
tulsa definitely
brought the brought the heat back and
speaking of hot man we have got a uh a
guest here today on cocktails and
cocktails that uh
man yeah he's not even worth it i mean
the heat came we'll just put it that way
when uh you know he was out there doing
his job and uh the the the heat came his
way but before we jump into talking with
our guests or even introducing him i
will say this our guest is from the
beautiful
kentucky
louisville
he is from louisville um and you and i
took a little trip to louisville
kentucky a few years ago and
we'll even be able to tie all that into
uh talking with our guests today and so
the bottle we're gonna sip on today is
blade and bow that we picked up actually
at the
stitzel weather
experience i think was the term of the
uh the thing it was an experience it was
an experience jason didn't make it jason
had a he had an experience the night
before and he was hungover so we had a
wonderful time there walked around we
walked around our guide at st to weller
he was a good three or four inches
taller than you yes and he wore um
overalls and he had more hair than very
hard on my back he looked like that
jason momoa dude
he did in overalls yeah
kentucky jason mamoa we're going to talk
about our guests we are so man we have
got uh now retired and correct me if i'm
wrong but sergeant john mattingly from
the louisville police department
thanks man good to be back john
thank you buddy so you know we were
obviously working through some technical
stuff before we got on as we mentioned
we are drinking
a little bit of uh bourbon here today
and you yourself though are drinking
something very very tough
that only guys with a stellar career
like yourself you know 2000 search
warrants and so forth would drink um
what are you having
i've got my wonderful iced coffee
iced coffee all right when you're when
you're a 49 year old and you've got a
seven-year-old boy that is a hundred
percent active all day all night dude
i've got to keep jesus flowing if i
start on the alcohol this early
yeah i'd be crashed you you have a
seven-year-old
yeah got a 25 23 22 and then seven
yeah i did the old car all the same four
same mother
no okay i was just gonna say that's the
question
yep yep well i will tell you that i had
a wonderful thing called a vasectomy
i did too and i had it for 10 years and
got it reversed reversed oh yeah i can't
know i came to i came to oklahoma and
did it
really kidding was it you know there's a
guy
out here in the uh
it's it's not even like one one of the
majors
he's not when it's not in one of the
major cities either in oklahoma right
it's kind of like a smaller place right
did you say owen wilson
no
david wilson was a doctor and he's not
even a urologist he's a vaso surgeon
and the dude's success rate is like
through the roof yeah
no well and i'm not i'm not going to
name a a senior police officer in my
department i know he went to him as well
and that's what why
he was married since he was like 22
years old ends up divorced married a
younger woman uh they are still together
she didn't she had never had kids one of
the kids and he wouldn't got it done and
i'm almost positive that is the same guy
uh guaranteed man he
he uh he's he's a he's an odd bird you
know you go there and he has no bedside
manners but you know he does his job and
it's all well he's working on balls all
day that'd be weird man you know it is
weird and and you stay awake the whole
time and it was like a two and a half
hour surgery it's it's not like the
original vasectomy where they give you a
couple shots snip snip burn so yep singe
on your way
you know they're having to go in there
out oh you get a ball lift i mean it's
amazing yeah
yeah well this and
i will say this
being the three of us have all had it
we're not going to turn this podcast
into it but for any guy out there
listening man
it is the having a vasectomy was such an
easy process i mean it's crazy how many
guys are scared to death of it
um i mean howard your nurse you're in
the nursing field what you know what i
mean i mean i popped some value they
gave you some valiums
and i had a couple beers to go with that
well i had it done on a college on a uh
on a friday
i laid around watch college football all
day saturday nfl all day sunday and at
the time i was working on a street
crimes unit on the police department you
know a plane closed deal and so i went
back to work and just that whole week i
worked in the office and then like a
week after that i was kind of back out
on the street it was no biggie yeah but
i know we're not here to talk to you go
ahead
yeah yeah i mean we kind of get off on
the tangent we just kind of go the way
it was no because i got a great story
with mine so go ahead with yours i'm
sorry i keep interrupting we got this
little dwelling going on but
since i'm in the medical field i knew
this urologist well he was a buddy of
mine i rode bikes with him and stuff so
i go in there and of course i go into
his office and i start calling him dr
soft hands
and his staff loves that you know so
he comes in and he's like hey you're
going to have this vasectomy this is the
chances of this chances of that goes
through the whole consent with me and
i'm like all right great
all right man when when you want to ride
again he was like now stand up put your
pants down i was like what
what are we doing a dress rehearsal here
he goes i need to get a look at him he
rolls up on the stool that's i don't
know three inches off the floor
comes up and grabs me and i'm just like
man dude i know you do this every day
but this is the weirdest thing ever so
thank goodness he has moved and i don't
have to know that he's fondled me
well i know you all got valium i know
y'all got valium uh david wilson does
not believe in narcotics evidently
because i got none just local
and uh when i left i thought well at
least he'll give me some hydrocodone or
something because i gotta fly back to
louisville the next day and i'm sitting
there thinking man this is horrible
he gives me a prescription for ibuprofen
and i'm like you gotta be kidding me of
all times legally on the police
department you can actually take
something and i get ibuprofen not only
that and it was a discounted rate and
this is why he left the tube the drain
tubes in and gave me some butterfly
stitches and these drain tubes these
drain tubes are held in by a
safety clip that are stuck through your
balls and clipped together
and so the next day i'm in there looking
down shaking you know sweat running down
my arms i've got to undo these safety
pins and pull them out and put the the
butterfly tape on
and so it was a it was a weird
experience
but it worked you're a newborn again so
that's it worked every day all right so
nobody knows uh i mean maybe some people
do but
john mattingly would be somebody if that
name came across i would think hey man
this guy coaches nfl right that's what i
would think
i would be confused and think that
but he's not i mean you had one of the
most high profile
cases
ever yeah i mean definitely in modern
law enforcement so john
i know you just retired from the police
department last year uh what year did
you come on there in louisville
2000 came on june 5th of 2000.
all right were you in law enforcement
prior to that somewhere else
no i didn't get until i was uh 27
because i i got married when i was 19.
kind of like your your boss you're
talking about i got married when i was
19 and my wife at the time was real
hesitant about it you know for the
safety issues and all that so
uh i didn't do it and then finally by
the time i was 20 i was like man this is
what i've always wanted to do it so i'm
just going to do it and maybe it was the
beginning of the end of my marriage i
don't know because three years in i was
divorced
uh found me a younger wife too i guess
man when you got on were you one of
those cops you know even though i i
assume louisville's like most larger
departments you get on you got to spend
your time on you know as a basic street
cop
and then eventually you can work
yourself into specialty units were you
one of those guys that especially being
a few years older obviously life
experiences but you were just like you
hit the streets and you were just like
bam bam bam let's go you know you wanted
to chase bad guys oh yeah i mean i would
have paid to go to work when we first
started i mean you just didn't want to
go home there's car chases foot chases
fights all the time and it was like
living a you know cops or live pd
episode every day and uh so i was on
late watch for the first five years and
probably the first three
we had a pretty tight core
and then guys started you know going to
different units and stuff and it just
wasn't the same so i started looking for
other other units to go to and uh in
2005 i went to what's called a flex unit
and uh it's basically a division level
narcotics type unit that was also
available for you know prostitution
details or uh carjacking details stuff
like that i did that until 2009 when i
got promoted uh the sergeant and i went
back to late watch for a year and that
about killed me man i i was older by
this time i've been off of it for a
while so i only did that for a year and
then i went to our division detectives
office for about a year and a half
and couldn't stand it i mean i liked the
guys but the suit and tithe thing wasn't
me
and
so i went to we were starting up a brand
new unit in the apartment because our
crime rate had just gone through the
roof in louisville and it was called
viper it was a violent crime unit and it
went after murder suspects shooting
suspects uh robbers carjackers all the
hardcore guys kind of like your gang
unit and uh
we did i did that for about three and a
half years and then i went to our major
narcotics division uh which is where i
was up until the time that uh briana
taylor case
and apologize we'll probably say
louisville but it's louisville for for
louisville's right
we love louisville louisville um
just talking about you
when you refer to i think the late shift
is that your graveyard shift that's the
overnight
yeah we were midnight to eight we were
still on eight hour shifts back then
they've they've since shifted uh 12-hour
shifts but yeah we were the midnight to
eight and then you know you'd have court
the next day at nine and then those
defense attorneys would drag you out to
11 and try to get you to leave and it
was it was miserable
good time no i i
i had it my
first year so at 23 years old i worked
our third shift is what we call it which
was 3 30 in the afternoon until 11 30 at
night
second year i didn't have any seniority
on the department we have what's called
a bid board every year didn't make the
third shift ended up on graveyards and
just how you were saying go back going
back to it later in your career you hate
it i didn't like it at 24.
um i think i was on there maybe three or
four months and then they end up having
a retirement from somebody in the third
shift or we had some rookies cut loose
or something like that and they opened
up a spot and i got to move to third
shift and
when i got promoted to sergeant i got
put on graveyards as well again for a
year
and about five months in then i broke my
hand in a fight at work
and luckily never had to go back to that
shift end up getting out of it but it's
there's guys that love it and it's great
for their families but
it's not for everybody
yeah that's the only reason
five years
go ahead how was the transition going
from eights to twelves and i know in
nursing we work twelves and man some of
those days get along
well i never did it as a protocol shift
now when you're narcotics every day is a
12-hour day um so it was different but i
but you're not tied to the radio so it
makes life a lot easier if you want to
go eat go eat if you move around move
around but uh those poor guys that are
tied to that radio they love the off
days they hate the ships by the time
their off days come and they're they're
they're wiped out
that's the other part what are they
working like three twelves then one week
four 12's the next something like that
it's a really weird split it's like two
on two off three on three off two it's
really bizarre i i never worked it so i
only heard it peripherally what they
were saying but yeah it's you from the
outside if you don't work the shift
you'll never get it down you're like
when's that guy working again i can't
remember one of those deals well
oklahoma city pd and i don't know if
they're still doing it they
recently they they work like eight days
on six days off
so i mean you think about it you're
getting like a almost like a vacation
every other week but dude you've got to
grind out eight days yeah um straight so
yeah eight on six off and then you know
just as you were talking about court i
mean think about it you're thinking
you've got a whole week off you're going
to get out of town you're going to run
to louisville louisville
and uh
yeah pick up some bourbon visit john
mattingly and uh next thing you know you
got court so all right so you're working
narcotics man um and obviously we're
going to get up here to the search
warrant with the uh that you know
they're brianna taylor's residents how
long were you in narcotics at the time
that this warrant was served
i went up there in 2016. so it had been
about three and a half years
all right
um your time in there i'm assuming
i don't want to say basic did somebody
by not any means a basic job but i mean
you guys are focused running informants
um you know search warrants by bus to
all the typical type of stuff narcotics
units to do is that correct
right and for about a year and a half uh
when i was in the major case unit i had
the tfos for the fbi and the dea that
uh reported to me so we did a lot of
stuff with them did wiretaps all that
type thing
then at the end i had just switched in
in september of that year because i knew
i had about five years left in me on the
police department that i wanted to work
before
you start losing money to come to work
and so i said i've seen so many guys and
i've been going hard my entire career i
wasn't one of those guys that just set
back
and
i said i want to do i want to start
slowing down a little bit i still want
to be involved that's the reason i never
took the promotional test lieutenant
because i saw those guys they get
promoted their pencil pushers they're
stabbing each other in the back trying
to climb rank had no desire for any of
that so when we were there i said i'm
going to switch over to our interdiction
unit which was partial parcel and street
interdiction the highway so i went there
because i thought you know boxes aren't
going to shoot back you might get a
paper cut that'd be about it and little
did i know it would it would lead me
right down this path
so if you're over there so at the time
that this happened the warrant you were
actually working in the interdiction
unit
yeah so the the unit inside our criminal
investigation division that's what it's
called that housed a narcotics
interdiction
and this unit called place based
investigation they got that from
cincinnati uh where they focus they
pinpoint focus on subjects that are
nuisances to the community
and
they re they sent out an email about two
weeks prior to the event and said hey
we've got five simultaneous warrants
we're doing super manpower intensive uh
is there any volunteers for overtime and
i was already working that night up
until 10 o'clock anyway and that's when
the brief started so i said hey i'm
already gonna be here i'll just jump
right in and keep working
all right what's interdiction mean
you're just intercepting like the main
thing we did we intercepted packages at
ups and fedex now we used to work with
the postal also but before i got there
there was a little pissing contest
between
uh postal in in our department and like
child like children they took their ball
and home uh so another uh department
worked with them with that but i mean
i'll give you an example we got to ups
and ups hates anybody telling the story
but
i don't work for them anymore so um we
would go out there one night a week and
ups we are the main hub for the united
states through louisville there will be
three million packages come through
there today we would go out there and
pull 20 20 packages that's all we'd pull
at night so we had a like a two-hour
window where we could identify packages
pull them have a dog sniff them if they
met the criteria write a warrant on them
open them up either they were good or
bad you'd have to tape them up put them
back before the plane went out or you
seized it and
so we would intercept 20 boxes a week
out of those boxes you could take a six
foot table and stack it four foot high
with drugs because the the postal
service the parcel services are the
biggest movers of dope in america
really oh yeah oh yeah i had no idea
yeah even out of our division you know
we had
ours was called sid you know special
investigation division and we had
dope dogs that worked out there and
there was a couple guys that's what they
did they went out there to
ups or whatever it was going they just
ran their dog out there just part of it
and
just to follow up on what he was saying
you do make an introduction you come
across a package and then
you know we're not a hub like you guys
are there so
the interdiction they're running here
it's going to be delivered in tulsa and
so it would basically have repackaged
and i mean this is not a secret but we
have
uh narcotics officers that obviously
wear plain clothes we have
fake uniforms for the various postal
carriers we did some browns we got some
browns what's brown done for you or
whatever and then they go make a
delivery you know they show up at the
house make a delivery people take it
we've got a search warrant prepared
already for the residents as soon as
they take it in you run a search warrant
and obviously catch them for the dope
so how do you pick
how do you pick 20 packages out of 3
million
well what you do is you you start with
source cities you look out west texas
california uh nevada different places
like that that are typical for where
your narcotics come up from from the
south and they get distributed and then
you look at the cities that it's going
to you know you got raleigh atlanta
louisville
different places that after time you
just kind of pick a pattern up like
everything else and then you look at
what we would do is we take the names on
the packages and we run them through one
of our programs that tells you whether
you know people's phone numbers and
stuff and if that information didn't
match up because generally they're
sending it to an address that doesn't
belong to them in a fake name
and that's kind of the case on brianna
taylor he this guy was using her to send
stuff to his house well obviously they
said well there's no packages going
there in his name well no kidding nobody
that's doing the dirt is going to put
their name on it that would just be you
know
suicide so
we would just look at those those things
then once you pull it off you know you
get it you look at it certain way
they're taped if it's got dope in it
usually every single seam is taped up on
it and you take it and you you put it
down with
five good boxes that are legit that
don't have any dope in it you got the
one mixed in there the dog runs the line
if he alerts on it then you pull it and
you write the write the warrant on it
so out of 20 what's your best haul in a
week
oh man i could send you picks probably
you know a couple kilos of fentanyl and
cocaine always weed you know a ton of
weed and we got near the end we got to
the point where we weren't even looking
for weed packages because you could
those are shooting fish in a barrel you
could get those all day long
the way they had them
yeah the way in the way they hide it you
know we we got they finally got us some
true narcs where we could you know laser
to see what we're dealing with so we're
not having to physically open every
package because you i mean you know
heroin has a specific smell cocaine has
a specific smell but you ain't gonna
sniff fentanyl unless you want to die so
uh you know we get to the point where we
just we laser them all and see what was
in it
yeah fentanyl's been part of the opium
epidemic i mean it's just killed tons
and tons and tons of people man yeah
that's that that that shit needs to get
off the streets i give it all the time
in the hospital but
i'm watching people like a hawk when i
do it i mean i think that's the number
one reason we have to give narcan to
everybody now oh absolutely well
especially out on the streets i mean
from the you know
ems and firemen and even cops obviously
that are carrying them in hell there's
there's federal grants out there now
that departments are getting so that
officers can carry narcan hey have you
heard of that
fentanyl that's
that
yeah the elephant tranquilizer yeah
man i heard a couple of we only saw it
twice
i've only seen it twice on all those
interdictions because generally that
shit's like hazmat too
oh yeah it's it's no it's no joke
all right john so you guys uh you
roughly how many warrants have you been
involved with during your career you
think
it's well over 2 000
that we've been through the door on
because you're looking at out of my 21
years
14 of them were spent on nothing but
these type specialty units and there are
some days many days during the week we
would do two or three a day
because we work with other units that
are like ours and we're constantly
pulling bodies hey we need help just for
you know two hours come over here hit
the door then go back to your thing or
your guys would have a warrant and i've
always been with guys because you know
as a boss shawn that
we're not the guys you know we're just
sitting there
we're holding the reins kind of
navigating things so i would always make
sure i had good guys under me that were
trustworthy that were able to do the job
and they make us just look like rock
stars you know everybody praised me and
i'm like oh i i don't like these
warrants i don't have these informants
these are these guys i was just spot on
lucky enough lucky enough to find the
right guys to put under me
no you know and i appreciate you saying
that because that is so true i was very
very fortunate and all the time you know
my my years in the gang unit and what we
call our crime gun unit and obviously i
did the media interviews um you know the
live pd thing that came along with it
and that was the first thing i always
said was hey listen man these are the
guys right here that are once busting
their ass i might be the face that gets
a talk to the media you know and talk
about the shooting or this arrest we've
helped out on this homicide or whatever
it is but the guys that were in that
squad man are the ones that busted their
ass and i've got two guys actually just
getting ready to get awards here next
month for gang investigator of the year
for a big long term t3 case they did on
one of our gangs and it's the same thing
we had all the media interviews and
you know the politics of policing just
like i do you know you've got
prosecutors and
other people that are up there on the
stage talking about how they stamped out
this group or this violent crime and
they didn't they didn't do a fucking
thing you know they're not the guys
doing the foot chases or kicking a door
down or you know you know talking to the
informant blah blah blah so uh
and that means a lot you saying that to
the guys that worked with you to other
cops
because there is nothing worse than a
supervisor
that takes all the credit for the work
his guys do
yeah and half these supervisors you
can't even find half the duty half the
time on duty they're off doing their own
thing
uh but yeah you talk about those the
bosses man i hate it when you know the
white shirts would all get on stage and
there'd be 10 or 12 of them
they wouldn't even talk to you and and
all of a sudden they're up there reading
some script that you gave and and
talking about the great job they did and
breaking their arms patting themselves
on the back and you're back they're just
throwing up going it's ridiculous you
know you just yep it makes you the same
as every everyday
same in every department well another
thing you said and uh we'll get into
obviously the incident but another one
you said spot on i never wanted to
promote either i never wan beyond the
rank of sergeant never wanted to go
higher had no desire to be a part of
administration i didn't want to be at
the mercy of the chief you know where he
wanted me to work and
like you said all the backstabbing that
goes on for people trying to work up
their vision commander and stuff all
right anyway so uh you guys are helping
out
no i kind of know it but i mean so
so i'll take you back just a little bit
this was like a two and a half three
month investigation that'd been going on
and they had full cams up trackers pings
on phones you know they were doing it
right and and what happened is jamarcus
glover who was the main ex-boyfriend but
the main guy in this ring
he had his
vehicle registered to brianna's house he
had his cell phone registered there he
had been bailed out of jail a couple
times over the past couple years the
most recent in january of 2020 brianna
bailed him out they used her address as
his address
his bank account was at her address so
everything pointed to her address which
in these scenarios
raises the red flags okay she's probably
holding the the money or maybe some dope
or at least some intel that's going to
tie in information on this ring where
they can have a better conviction in
court so that's how that's how her
apartment got tied into it and yes cal
right so what brought
go ahead so back to my question is as
you had been kind of stinging this
through what you've been finding at ups
and packages being delivered is that how
this originally started
no they they started with because the
the the mayor
it's all
it's it's really hairy the mayor wanted
to redevelop this area on elliot avenue
they had had the plans drawn up for a
couple years it was gentrification is
what it was and got you they wanted to
bring in this big project they had the
plans drawn up they kept sending emails
going we got to get these people out of
these houses they even sent a map out
that showed the houses the city had
already taken over and the ones they
needed and two of them were the ones
they were hitting that night so that was
the real story behind it it wasn't that
this guy was such a nuisance to the
community that everybody was complaining
he was a bad dude you know a bunch of
drug and gun charges but he was not the
worst of the worst in our city far from
it and but the mayor was really pushing
pushing pushing this thing and we you
know as the police department you have
no idea why you just follow commands it
goes to your major down to your
lieutenant to your sergeant to you and
they're going okay we'll hit this area
okay here's the here's the complaint i
have in hand this is where i'm going and
that's what they were doing now they did
have packages of him uh going to
brianna's house they've got pictures of
him going in with nothing coming out
with packages but again when they ran
that through postal nothing came back in
his name
okay gotcha
right that's why i was getting confused
the ups thing man all right thanks for
clairing that so multiple there's five
search warrants that are being run your
team's running one at the apartment of
brianna
and what time of night is this
12 40 when we hit the door
12 40 48 a.m
yeah okay so you guys had an early
early morning of friday the 13th full
moon out it was it was great
wow and and ironically i know this is
you know we're not supposed to
date the date we're doing this podcast
but we are actually doing this thing
here on uh saturday the 14th so it's uh
two years ago right
yep no three years ago two years ago it
is two years ago yeah two years ago yeah
so that's another right third three
months
no okay so uh
your team at 12 40 a.m um obviously a
lot of talk still a continuing talk
about no knocks and all this type of
stuff and and i know that you guys
despite having a no knock warrant did
not announce your presence
uh right
but you had you obviously listen to get
a no knock warrant there are certain
things that have to go in the affidavit
that a judge has to sign off on to get a
night service warrant which you guys
obviously were doing there are certain
things that have to go in the warrant
that a judge themselves have to sign on
an officer just doesn't get to fill out
an affidavit and go hey we want to go
hit howard doss's house at
2 a.m without knocking on the door and
the judge assigns it there's a lot of
other things that have to go in there
so if you guys are running five warrants
this time of night obviously every
affidavit for every residence
had all of these specific things in them
correct
correct and the reason the reason the no
knock was signed for all of them is
because they didn't know exactly where
jamarcus glover would be and he was the
reason for the no knock as far as his
violent pass the guns uh the evading
police all that stuff all those factors
came into play and when we got to the
brief that night they changed it from a
no knock to vet one only as a knock and
announce because it no longer fit the
parameters of the no not now we could
have kept it we could have done
something that was kind of
you know a little iffy grayish area but
they did the right thing and they said
it doesn't fit the parameters let's
change it to a knock and announce they
even said she's a heavyset black female
she's there at home alone so they
thought they said give her extra time to
come to the door
which
every time in my career it seems like
shannon or howard that i've gone against
what i've always done or something that
wasn't my decision that you go i don't
really like that but if you ask me do it
i'll do it it seems like something bad
happens and that's what we did that
night because the typical knocking
announces five to ten seconds you're
knocking your announce and you're not
gonna announce and giving them time if
you don't hear anything you pause you
hit the door well this was almost a
minute knocking and banging on this door
and that seems like an eternity when
you're on the other side of something
that of the unknown on the other side
now for your department do you guys or
did you guys i know you're now retired
but
prior to i think there was a i don't
remember was a policy change within the
agency or something even at the state
level i think they've taken away no
knock warrants there for you guys prior
to that though were no knock warrant
something that was
you you guys regularly did there in now
in louisville
no i think there was five total the
previous year
uh five or six so they were a rare thing
and they act like
and the thing that ticks me off the most
because like i'm a rand paul guy what he
just did the other day was great i
thought blocking that that 40 billion
dollar stimulus package going to ukraine
but
one of the things he did because you
know he's uh a libertarian that he he
wants less police in in your lives or
less government we all do nobody wants a
government in your life but when you got
bad guys that are that are problematic
to the community somebody's got to step
in
and you know when he got his his
jaw broke or whatever he got by that guy
that hit him his neighbor he wanted the
police to step in
but he used this as a platform
and he actually called it the justice
for brianna taylor act and i'm sitting
at home going you've got to be kidding
me you know this is a guy i supported
and voted for
and he's totally twisting the narrative
of this because it wasn't a no knock and
it had already been told at this time
that it wasn't a no knock yet you know
he still capitalized that on to pass a
bill and to push it through
and in the state they can't i think
there's still some exigent circumstances
maybe like homicide suspect or
kidnapping that they can do it but uh
yeah it's very narrow now and nobody
will even apply for it
well and and
you know i was on our swat team for
seven years started serving search
warrants back in our street crimes unit
which would have been in 2000
to i think 2000 you know in two years we
ran a shitload of them i was in
narcotics for a year i was in gangs for
i don't know 12 years whatever same type
of deal we ran
a ton and ton and ton of search warrants
and despite all of that i think on sot
when i was on swat we might have ran one
no knock warrant and the way that it's
been portrayed by
media and you know anti-police people
politicians it is such a rare occurrence
at least for most of the agencies that i
know of it's just not something that is
done all that often and uh but you know
yeah obviously the anti-police sentiment
that was already going on and
things were turned slanted i mean
everything from
this was a no knock warrant to she was
sleeping in her bed et cetera et cetera
but so you guys get up there you knock
on the door
a minute goes by and then at some point
you guys breach the door and you guys
doing the standard you know you've got a
ram type of deal to breach the door yeah
yeah so i'm on the left side of the door
the door swings from right to left my
part or the the breachers on the right
so he can hit the door and as it comes
open i can see through you know to the
part that that gets exposed
um it was a it was a
breezeway so it's kind of a small area
it was an eight plex you had four up
four down a metal staircase that went up
by her door uh so the breach was right
there at the staircase underneath it
and uh when he hit it on the third hit
it came open
and i cleared what i could of the right
and once i ran out of real estate with
my visual you know you've gotta at some
point you gotta go in and the thing that
people leave out on no knocks everybody
assumes if it's a no-knock warrant they
don't you're not announcing yourself
there's never been one time on a search
warrant that even even on no knocks in
the past that we've done where you're
still not announcing yourself once that
door is hit because you want them to
know you're the police you know at this
point the gig's up the door's being hit
the noise is being made so now i'm
letting you know i'm the police so you
don't shoot me that's the whole point of
it
and uh so the the fact that people say
okay well they did not because kenneth
walker the guy that shot me did say they
knocked but now they didn't announce you
know first is they didn't knock or
announce now then it was well they
knocked for a minute but they didn't
announce so he didn't know who we were
and all that's just asinine
and i'll tell you some more stuff about
him in a minute it goes to his character
about how much he lies but
you know it's it's people gotta
understand that just because you quote
eliminate no knocks doesn't mean you're
gonna change the effect of what a
criminal is gonna do in their mindset
right so you clear to the right you turn
to the left and then what happens next
as soon as i step in the doorway so i
step in the door frame and come around
uh from my right to left and down this
narrow hallway probably 25 30 feet very
dark there's some ambient light coming
out from the tv in the bedroom i got a
gun a real amount of light on my on my
pistol because again our department is
so great they had changed the rules
about five years ago where we couldn't
use long rifles on search warrants or
shotguns everything's pistol and there's
no optics just hard sights
so come around the corner and down the
hall i see something totally different
than i'd seen in all these warrants and
you know when something when something
happens different your mind's just going
oh some this is bad so i look down the
hall and there's two subjects
overlapping one another one taller one
smaller and this is what it looks like
and
one tall head one short head
but then i just see the barrel of a gun
as i'm coming from right to left i stop
at him i never even got over to brianna
taylor because everything's happening in
milliseconds i mean this is going down
quick i go right to left and and i see
the pistol and boom it's over he shoots
and so i get off four rounds as quick as
i can i go behind the door frame to my
left come back around and put two more
in where he had jumped into a bedroom uh
they hit the door frame there and by
that time i reached down and felt my leg
and i'd seen so many people shot over
the years i knew
this wasn't just a through and through
because my hand was just saturated with
blood and so i knew it was some artery
that had been hit so i i even announced
it to the guys right there at the door i
said man i've been hit it hit my femoral
and i went down on my butt because i'm
thinking in my mind i'm thinking you
know you think some weird stuff when
this is happening i'm thinking if i
stand up and keep moving i'm pumping my
blood harder and it's going to pump out
so i go down to my rear end as i do that
miles steps up over me and he's putting
uh rounds down range so i can get out of
there
and so i jump up and hobble off and as i
go to the curb i stumble over it because
my left leg didn't really work and the
the muscles totally shut down at this
point
and i step off the curb and go to the
ground as i'm going down i look over and
my buddy mike is laying down between the
cars he was the last one in the stack
and when the shot rang out he stepped
back and tripped over the curb
and so i'm and i go down i'm looking at
him thinking oh crap mike's been shot so
when i hit the ground i holster my
weapon i said man are you all right he
said i'm good so i'm like i need a
tourniquet i just started saying i need
a tourniquet so i'm trying to put
pressure on it tell him i need a
tourniquet about that time my lieutenant
comes up grabs my vest from behind
slides me out from between the two cars
into the parking lot and they get
working on my leg
so somebody they're
one of the guys they end up having a
tourniquet and slapping it on you
yeah originally my lieutenant didn't
have one because i love the guy but you
know how lieutenants are they you're
lucky to find their guns so he pulls his
belt off aren't you telling me
well our departments change the rank of
sergeant two lieutenant there wasn't a a
promotion they just got rid of the title
all star just became lieutenants all
corporals became sergeants i would still
be nice if if the pay bump came with it
nope nothing
here's what it
you know what listen i hate to stop this
story but our department all the
supervisors that those ranks got to vote
and what they were saying was our lodge
was saying it's how we can compare
ourselves to other agencies that are
roughly our same size for pay and you
know because these agencies refer to
their sergeants as lieutenants and so of
course all the corporals on that
apartment they were like hell yeah i
want to be called a sergeant and a lot
of the sergeants were like hell yeah i
want to be called a lieutenant and i was
one of and i'm not joking a handful out
of hundreds and hundreds of supervisors
that voted for it i said hell no i
didn't want i wanted a state sergeant so
that's why i'm always still sergeant
sean stixlark
hey sean you know uh
you know what fathers love doing
um
i i got a whole list of things i like
doing as a father yeah well i'll tell
you what a lot of fathers like they like
peace and quiet and one of the places
they could get some peace and it's not
so quiet is mowing the lawn yes mowing
the lawn whether it be the yard out in
front or behind the house or the one
below on the body right or on the back
side of the body right or any of those
places but if you're gonna mow the lawn
what do you need you need a lawn mower
the new lawnmower 4.0 4.0 it's a big one
they sent us some of these we tried it
out not on each other we've we've done
it on the own privacy of our home we did
try it out on each other but we're not
going to tell everybody that the uh and
man these are awesome no they actually
they are fantastic listen i have uh
my entire adult life um i have been a
fan of
body maintenance i guess would be the
term to use
body hair maintenance hygiene exactly
it's for a hygiene thing um and i've
gone through different things through
the years and this manscape 4.0 the
lawnmower 4.0 i'm sorry that was sent
out to us uh it's a great little box
game with all kinds of stuff man you got
that you got the 4.0 in there you got a
little nose trimmer
you got a pair of underwear yeah and
you've got that ball deodorant
excuse me you have that
no no square deodorant yes the no no
yeah so it's it's a hell of a kit that
they send out and listen for all the
listeners out there whether you are a
man yourself and you're looking for
something to keep the body looking
trimmed up uh you yourself have a father
the the young you know the wives that
are out there and so forth
get on manscape.com get yourself that
kit get it sent out to the house and
keep your man and your daddy
well
anyways whether you got it yeah whether
you're using your dad or your daddy
and trim keep them trimmed and you can
use code sticks
on there as well s-t-i-c-k-s
manscape.com yes
okay sorry go back
so so what's this leather belt
go ahead yeah what was going through
your mind after you've been shot and it
was femoral and you had dropped to i
mean you did the right thing you
shouldn't be running around on that leg
that does cause a little bit more blood
to flow through there so what's going on
on in your mind where you're being
dragged backwards
well the whole thing i just kept saying
dude i need a tourniquet i need a
tourniquet because i knew i knew i had a
time frame right what is it five to
eight minutes something like that right
that you gotta get that you gotta get
this thing on and so
i knew it time was of the essence and i
wanted to make sure we could find
because i didn't know if there was one
or two holes i had no idea because
everything happened so quick and it was
so loud in that in that little breezeway
because the metal and all the stuff that
i wasn't sure who shot what you know at
this point and so i'm thinking
for some reason god kept my mind calm
and i remember everything that happened
and i was telling people what to do go
there do this stop that and i remember
hearing brett going they've got a rifle
they shot with a rifle and i'm laying on
my back as they're trying to get this
tourniquet on and i said i remember
leaning i'm going no it was a pistol
because i remember seeing it
and so um
just some of those things are just you
know instinctive when you've been a boss
for so long you just can't help yourself
and so they tried this leather belt and
my buddy mike who had stepped he stepped
on my leg to try to pull it up because
they couldn't get it tight there was so
much blood it just kept slipping so
finally the guy with the tourniquet came
up they got it on me and i remember i
felt more pain in my groin and my lower
back than i did where the bullet
actually went in and so as they put the
turnkey i'm like wait a minute get a
knife cut it up i i want to make sure
you're high enough because it felt like
it was higher than where they were
putting it and i knew that was shot
there because that's where the blood was
coming out but i didn't know if the
bullet had gotten lodged up deeper in me
or what had happened
and i had a i was wearing a wallet in my
front pocket that had a little metal
clip in it and that bullet came through
my leg and that diverted it from hitting
my femur
but it went over and ripped through the
femoral artery and
um so they end up taking i think eight
inches of that out and replacing with a
vein
um but so but while i'm laying there i'm
thinking man i really just got shot so
i remember pulling out my phone and
calling my wife because i thought i
don't want her to get that knock at the
door and be freaked out
and so i called her it rang went to
voicemail she'd taken an ambien that
night was out
and so i started to leave a a voice
message for my family just in case i
died because you don't know
and i was doing that and mike looked at
me what are you doing and you can hear
this on video because by that time the
body cam guy got in there with the beat
guy
and he yanks out on my hand he said i'll
take care of that well then he forgets
and leaves the phone on the ground the
whole time because i i sit there and
gave you my password told him where my
wife was staying because we just sold
our house and we're staying with a
friend we were in transition
to buying this new house
and so they didn't know where she was so
fortunately one of my other guys i used
to work with knew some of our mutual
friends got on facebook found out where
they lived through accurate uh ran to
their house grabbed him up took him
where she was staying woke her up scared
her to death you know all the typical
stuff
um but yeah it was a it was an
experience
man uh john so when you're shot and
there you know the guys are working on
you and eventually get the tourniquet on
you did you guys have you know ems on
stage close by did you get load and go
up in another vehicle how'd you end up
not at the hospital
so ems was like less than a half mile
away they're always on standby on our
warrants uh right what i didn't know and
what i i've petitioned them to change
but they haven't they've changed nothing
after this not any way they serve
warrants ems protocol any of this they
had two
i think they're called class a which are
just simple life-saving emts no
paramedic no stage two whatever that's
called i can't remember so you can't
administer certain medicines they know
basically cpr and how to put a bandage
on you and get you to the hospital
and when i powered with them
they're truck drivers
exactly just truck drivers bad truck
drivers let me tell you that so i pulled
up when we were doing the brief the
secondary brief on on location i'll pull
up and they're sitting there stationed
and i go up and i'm trying to get their
attention this one guy the driver is
sitting there with his headphones on
he's got braids
the other young guy they're both
probably 21 22 i mean they look younger
than my kids i had one black guy one
white guy black guy sitting there with
headphones on the white guy's over there
so entrenched in his phone they didn't
hear me honk i finally get my flashlight
out getting their eyes they look over he
can't get the headphones unlatched out
of his hair they're stuck and i remember
telling the guy with me i went god i
hope these aren't the guys that have to
save my life
because i'm thinking they were they yeah
and nothing against them you could just
tell zero experience and the funny thing
is when i get when they finally get me
to the wagon which took them about 12
minutes to get there because they didn't
hear the radio call i don't know if they
were still on the phone headphones
totally missed it
and i'm thinking because they went do
you want us to load you up and go and
normally i would say yes and i've always
said my entire career if i get shot load
me up let's go but we're about 25
minutes from the hospital that i've
needed to go to the one with the trauma
unit and it's raining out
the good hey listen i know the same ones
in tulsa if you're shot there's certain
hospitals you want to go to another
that's it
and so and it's raining out and i know
how cops drive and i knew everybody was
you know adrenaline was through the roof
and i'm thinking if they throw me in the
back of this car i know this dude's
gonna drive like an idiot and kill us
all i said no ems is close just wait
just give them a minute because i knew
how close they were and i thought i'd
rather be in the back of that getting
something done to me than in the back of
a car and having a wreck so they finally
get there
and they carry me they get me to the
ambulance they put me on the back of a
car in a trunk because they couldn't get
through because of gate
they they bring me down because they
came in the wrong entrance
so they drive me down there they get me
to the back of this wagon
they open the door my lieutenant's
carrying me at this point i'm 200 pounds
you know with all the gear it's about
240 and i can hear him just ah you know
he's breathing thank god he was a
college athlete and played baseball and
so he at least had some skills and uh
he's six six so he was able to step over
this gate and all these things so
he gets me there and they start to pull
the gurney out and i remember thinking
you're idiots i grabbed the gurney why
he's holding me and i push it back in
and say i'm here now let's go yeah and
they put me in they put me and one of
the other guys jumps in with me but i
think my lieutenant is throwing up and
needing oxygen and
uh he's standing there one guy's
standing to my left one guy's standing
my right my buddy's standing right there
and it's just silence we're sitting
there and i'm looking at him i go
what are we doing and and my buddy goes
do you need me to drive and the little
white kid went no i got it and he
disappeared he's like man i want nothing
to do with this i'm done
so he jumps up front
yeah the black guy steps up he's going
he's just looking around looking around
and i look at him i go dude am i your
first gunshot victim he kneels down
close to me and he goes hey to be honest
you are and i said listen
this is the first time i've been shot so
let's not screw this up well he was he
was like a deer in headlights man he
never put a finger on me never touched
me never did anything about that time
that's probably good
oh yeah the back doors came open and
there was two paramedics from the fire
department standing there and i happen
to know one of them and he looks at me
and he goes i didn't expect it to be you
i said thank god at you let's go they
jump in a man they get working i mean
they were just they were perfect and
they just kicked this guy away and said
keep our times that's all he did keep
her times
and uh the funny thing is about four
months later this guy gets on social
media and says had i known this guy was
a monster that had murdered a black
woman while she was sleeping and all
this stuff i would have never saved his
life and i'm thinking
oh man you didn't do shit man you didn't
do nothing you got in the way is all you
did uh so that's that's just the kind of
crap we're dealing with
well let's talk about that for a second
so the the perception is is you shot
somebody when they were sleeping it
sounds like you shot down a hallway
where two people were
one was
being used as a shield it sounds like
right
yeah so what happened was
there was an inset on on the wall next
to kenneth walker so a three foot three
foot hallway she's a big girl he's not a
small guy he's about six two wide not
fat but he's wide she's she's big
they're crammed in this hallway but
there's an inset that goes into one a
bedroom door here and then to the very
left of them their bedroom
and as soon as he shot he dove out of
the way i mean boom he jumped left her
hanging there she tried to follow him in
and due to the forensics you can see the
blood trail where she was almost in that
room when she got struck and then the
blood circles back around and she falls
back the opposite way her feet are where
he went into and her head's back up
against the wall on the other side
so he was just a coward because his big
thing was oh man we were getting home
invaded i thought we were getting home
invaded well if you do that why would
you bring your girlfriend out in the
hallway with you why would you go hey
get in the closet and call 9-1-1 i'll
take care of this you know until you get
the police on the way but they didn't do
that and then when it was over who did
he call he called his mom
he called his mom he stayed in this
apartment for 16 minutes before he came
out and they could get help to her which
she'd already passed by this time but he
stayed in there he had hidden his gun
and then he said well i dropped my gun
under a bed when you first shot i'm
thinking if you thought you were getting
homovated you would have retrieved that
gun and been and waiting for them to
come back in but it's all lies because
he called his mom and his mom told an
officer on scene who happened and went
to school with kenneth walker and knows
them she said kenny called me and said
mom they're at the door she said who's
at the door baby he said it's the police
i gotta go
well that was never brought up in the
media that was never told about and so
then when he comes out when he gets
arrested listen to this when he gets
arrested he comes out and this is all on
body cam they're going who else is in
the house who else is in the house he
said my girlfriend she's dead where is
she she's down the hallway all right was
where's the gun it's her gun it's inside
well who shot the police she shot she
was scared so then he blamed her for
shooting us
so this dude's character is just i mean
no credibility whatsoever but the press
believed him over seven cops that had
over 140 years experience in this game
and it's just unbelievable the
roadblocks that we faced over and over
and you know 26 months later 26 months
in guys
our city in our department has not
debunked one of the rumors they've never
come out and said no they were at the
right place
no she wasn't in bed
no the other guy wasn't in prison
already or in jail like you all said no
they weren't there to rob people no all
these things that were lied about
they've never come out and spoken up for
us not one time
so even after the fact
obviously charges were not brought
against you and uh one of the other
officers and i apologize what was the
other officer that fired i mean i know
there were three of you
miles was cosgrove's one that stepped
over me brett's the one that circled
around and shot through the windows
right and so brett ended up having the
the was it the wontons
or whatever it is yeah yeah one
endangerment three three counts of one
endangerment and then
and he went to trial and it took a jury
less than three hours or roughly three
hours to find him not guilty so despite
you guys were
justified in what you did
one of the officers that is charged is
found not guilty still nobody from your
own agency at any level has stood up and
spoke to the media about it not one none
of the politicians in town
uh and this just gives you kind of a
a feeling of what it was like so our
city council president his name is david
james
he was a retired cop he did 20 years on
our department retired went to another
department for about five years got
elected to city council became president
over a couple of years he trained me in
the academy he's the one that taught us
about search warrants when i did search
warrant classes he taught us all these
things that we did
and now he's a city council president so
i thought well maybe i've gotten out
here you know maybe i've got somebody
who can kind of come to our defense
black guy he's got some respect in the
community former cop this could be good
so when things start picking up because
originally with covid this thing kind of
got pushed to the side because on march
13th when the nation shut down
so there's press conferences every day
for that and i thought and it shouldn't
be this way because but ever since
ferguson what's the first question you
asked sean when they're shooting were
they black or white shouldn't be that
way it just should be was it a good
shooter bad shoot period well it's all
it's not it's not say it's not the
officers that are asking it it is
i mean literally command staff people
ask it i have been on shootings where
officer involved shootings that people
who
are very anti-police you know or
that you know they are very fortunate
they get the microphone in front of them
every time they they are upset about
something the police i know a specific
shooting one of the guys in my squad was
in and shot and killed you know a dude
shot at him and he he shot him and
killed him killed the suspect
and this guy within our community who is
very anti-police
he showed up and that was the first
thing he asked and when he found out it
was a white dude he left wanted nothing
it didn't matter then and that's the
whole point and sorry to take over that
but that's the thing not any shooting a
good shooting what we call good and bad
when we say good or bad we mean legally
justified is what we mean exactly right
none of that matters and and listen any
cop in america
any person that poses a threat to them
and is shooting at them or whatever we
don't give a shit nobody we don't
you know it's like
his gun didn't his gun didn't care that
i was white or that that he was black it
just he just pulled the trigger and shot
and uh right yeah we we had a we had a
colonel when i was on scene of a
shooting officer-involved shooting
she called and this guy shot at our guys
they shot back she called and i'm
standing next to the person she's
talking to my boss
and she didn't say are the officers okay
she said was asses was the suspect black
or white that's all they cared about and
i'm going man this is ridiculous man
that you know the path we've gone on and
again it started back in 2014 15 15
especially once that took place with
ferguson um things just kind of went
downhill we kind of rebounded some never
got back to where we were but now you
know those poor guys are down in the
gutter again dealing with all this crap
man you know and we've only got a minute
or two left and i apologize because i
felt like we could talk to you for two
more hours but we cut all that vasectomy
stuff out see that that's a pun
cut it out
yeah but howard and i we uh we did we
ended up in louisville this that summer
and we uh were there as
two things covid was happening and
protest from the brianna taylor deal so
we were there we stayed what three or
four nights we did man we went around
drank corn liquor we had a good time
yeah so i mean everything was shut down
we were uh you know we're nice guys we
were able to work our way into
establishments uh that were shut down
and for quote unquote private parties
and and have a good time but we were
there and watching the protests and and
got an opportunity to speak to a lot of
the police officers that were there and
just how they were getting their ass
kicked man the the hours the
the fact that they weren't really
allowed to do anything while the you
know the the damage that was happening
in the city and everything i mean
everything was boarded up and when i
describe it to people i say man it looks
like what florida or something looks
like when a hurricane is getting ready
to come through yeah absolutely
everything in downtown louisville was
boarded up on the lower level and
everything had graffiti on it and
damaged and stuff like that and we were
at a great uh cuban restaurant
um on in new life
yeah yeah that's it man those guys are
and that's well and that's what so they
were open during this and we went in
there and there was a couple of uh
louisville police officers that were
working it and you know recognize me
from the show and we came through i
started talking with them for a while
and that's what they're saying just how
crazy you know it was going on here and
how the owners
of that restaurant
refused to
and listen i'm just going off of what
they had told me these officers told me
but that basically some blm groups there
or people affiliated with blm were
basically demanding all the businesses
down in that area
be anti-police essentially putting stuff
up in their windows about what was going
on and that owner refused to do it and
how he had received threats about his
place getting burned down and so that's
why the officers were there working and
that's just the stuff that you guys had
to deal with down there well let's roll
this back again what's the name of this
mayor
greg fisher
all right so this summer bitch wants to
get he he wants to do some community
development he wants to gentrify an area
and so he sends the cops in to do his
work nobody's talked about that son of a
bitch i mean no i'll tell you what they
did they did talk about that when when
brianna taylor's family
redid the lawsuit they had found out
this information somebody given it to
them they introduced that in the lawsuit
within two days they settled the lawsuit
for 12 million dollars this is before
any criminal court before anything else
happened before any of the information
was was revealed he gave him 12 million
dollars because fisher did not want to
go and have to give testimony he stayed
far away
because he's a corrupt crook that's what
he is
fucking got shit stains in his goddamn
shorts now that's ridiculous man and
that's the thing that doesn't get out
there i mean we get played in the
media's like three guys come in there's
an innocent person sleeping on a couch
and we shoot at her because we shoot at
people that are sleeping on couches
that's just what we do that's what
lebron said it's just what we do
well i think the beauty of this is and
this is the whole reason that we have
this podcast again i'm fucking liberal
as shit but i am very
prone to listening to the truth and this
is what we have here we've got the truth
you were there it's called common sense
howard it's called common sense yeah i
guess we don't have that guess what else
you got fucking shot dude it's not like
you were just some you were you were so
predator there i mean you got no oprah
said that oprah said we had a
confrontation me and the boyfriend had a
confrontation then i shot
yeah she left that oh yes
i said a lot of these people that say
these type of things and at all levels
of life whether it's the famous people
or even you know low
regular people of life they've never
ever
been in these type of situations
obviously
but they've never a lot of them have
never been the victims of violent crime
you know they say all this shit and
they've never seen what the fuck goes on
out there how about this how about just
fucking get the facts man yeah shocker
let's just get the motherfucking facts
let's not you would say not
let's not go on conjecture man let's not
listen to bullshit let's not listen to
gossip let's just hear the facts and so
guess what yeah and if we're if we're
wrong
we pay for it i think it's the way it is
absolutely important and that shit
happens yeah there are officers that pay
for it as they should you know when they
are in fact in the wrong all right real
quick john before we get out of here man
you have obviously since recovered uh
kudos to you health-wise is good
yeah not bad no complaints got legs
still numb knee still gives me issues
once in a while but yeah i'm great how's
the vasectomy
oh beautiful have you had a second
vasectomy no no okay last question just
cutting on those
yeah yeah
hey you got two of them cut the other
side you look like joan your balls are
gonna look like joan river's face man
too much work
they're supposed to be obviously
no
botox them
and this episode is brought to you by
manscape that's right
no but so you've obviously got the book
that's out there you got the beautiful
background behind you where can people
find your book where can they find you
if they want to reach out to you or
follow you through social media
it's anywhere books are sold online
amazon target walmart any that
in stores books a million and barnes
noble and let me give you a little
teaser on the book because there's a ton
of stuff we couldn't get to today
i talked in there about a hit that was
placed on us for fifty thousand dollars
by brianna taylor's mother
and because she's part of a black biker
club gang
and then i tell you the corruption of
the fbi
and the links
where
they came in and shut down the
investigation because the optics looked
bad going after a black female on a
national stage so all that's in the book
get it you'll be enlightened you'll see
some stories other other things about my
career early on and i think you'll
really enjoy easy read written by a cop
didn't have a ghostwriter just sat down
did it myself so it's super easy anybody
can read it no big words
and what's the name of it
12 seconds in the book
12 seconds in the dark by sergeant john
maddenly
hey it was a pleasure to have you sir we
really appreciate you telling us our uh
telling your story and we're glad you're
healthy now man
i appreciate it guys
all right take care
[Music]